we've been hearing from Donald Trump and
Trump's kids and Trump's associates and
Trump's advisers and Trump's attorneys
and Trump's dog walker dentist and
barber anybody who we've heard from says
Trump didn't do business with Russia he
didn't want to do business with Russia
there were no connections to business
with Russia and it's now been learned
thanks to the Washington Post reporting
that while Donald Trump was running for
president the Trump Organization was
trying to develop a Trump Tower Moscow
Moscow happens to be in Russia in case
he didn't know and one of the people
involved is Felix Sater a name that is
pretty familiar to us at this point
developer Felix aider predicted in a
November of 2015 email that he and Trump
organization leaders would be
celebrating one of the biggest
residential projects in real estate
history and Donald Trump's election as
president according to two of the people
with knowledge of the exchange Seder
wrote to Trump Organization executive
vice president Michael Cohen something
to the effect of can you believe two
guys from Brooklyn are going to elect a
president Seder came from what was then
the Soviet Union when he was six years
old and grew up in Brooklyn so he's
talking about Cohen and himself Seder
himself is quite a character he served
time in jail after assaulting a man with
the stem of a broken margarita glass
during a 1991 bar fight but hey who
hasn't done that right I mean we've all
been in those situations that escalate
and you've got to attack someone with a
broken glass this went as far as to
having a letter of intent signed by
Donald Trump's company but they ended up
without the permits and the land to move
forward with the project and then the
primaries were starting up in January of
2016 and this project for a Trump Tower
Moscow was ultimately abandoned so
Trump's story all along has been there's
just nothing at all in terms of business
with Russia we already knew that to be
false since he did hold that pageant in
Russia and his kids were doing business
there too but let's ignore that for now
and now we've learned that a project
fell through which led to Trump not
doing this project in Russia
there was nothing about Trump's desires
that prevented this business with Russia
from being done he was actively pursuing
business deals in Russia while
campaigning for the presidency of the
United States and the records related to
this entire Fiasco are going to become
part of the various investigations into
Trump Russia the White House was asked
to comment on this bombshell from The
Washington Post they declined
Trump's lawyer Michael Cohen was asked
to comment about this he declined
Trump's lawyers lawyer Stephen Ryan said
that hey Michael Cohen's cooperating
with the investigations and I want to
call your attention to something else
once again the Trump Russia blackmail
dossier or the Christopher Steele
blackmail file call it whatever you want
right one of the assertions of that
dossier a growing list of which have
been proven to be true over time one of
the assertions from the Christopher
Steele file was that one of the ways
Russia was cultivating Trump as a
friendly figure to them was with the
promise of lucrative real-estate deals
and that also appears to be true but
it's all been lie after lie after lie
here's another example of how this
entire thing is riddled with lies from
Trump remember that interview with the
New York Times that Donald Trump did
must have been maybe six weeks ago at
this point there was one point where
Trump was asked by both Schmidt and and
Maggie Haberman who were in the room
with him Schmidt said last thing if
Muller was looking at your finances and
your family finances unrelated to Russia
is that a red line Maggie Haberman came
in and said would that be a breach of
what his actual charge is and Donald
Trump said I would say yeah I would say
yes by the way I would say I don't I
don't I mean it's possible that there's
a condo or something so you know I sell
a lot of condo units and somebody
somebody from Russia buys a condo who
knows so the implication is there might
be some stray real estate sale
was done to some someone from Russia
because he sells a lot of condos but
that's it however according to Reuters
we have now learned that quote in the
United States members of the Russian
elite have invested in trunk buildings a
Reuters review is found at at least 63
individuals with Russian passports or
addresses have bought at least 98 point
four million dollars worth of property
in seven trump branded luxury towers in
southern Florida according to public
documents interviews and corporate
records it is all lies it is all lies
and we're learning more and more about
the specifics of those lies every week
Felix Sater may well be the sort of
original Trump Russia connection that
led to everything we've seen since we'll
see what else we learned from the
Washington Post over the next 24 or 48
hours about this today's program is made
possible by taga dabbe the hosting
specialists offering a range of flexible
hosting packages including dedicated VPS
and cloud server options as well as
custom server solutions and uk-based
colocation services for your business or
project taga DAB's web hosting services
support a wide range of customers and
businesses worldwide including bloggers
tech startups financial traders gamers
web developers and more and taga dab has
a really user-friendly interface so you
don't have to worry about being super
tech savvy they can automate almost
everything you need for total ease of
use they are really proud of their team
of expert hosting specialists who are
also their support team 70% of their
business comes from repeat orders and
recommendations with a growing number of
people interested in moving their
businesses and projects to the cloud
taga dab is currently offering our
viewers and listeners a twenty british
pound free credit about twenty four US
dollars to all customers signing up to
give you a chance to try the service
this is a limited availability offer
first-come first-served for viewers and
listeners of the David Pakman show to
take advantage of it go to signup tag a
DAB com forward slash
TDPS and use the offer code TDPS 20 all
one word all lowercase
during account registration